destruction lines the road to felica
Nova silke
All That Remains of this front-line town
is rubble and memories
sounds of nearby fighting echo down the
streets you can get a sense of the
intensity of the fighting with the smell
of gunpowder in the air
nearby Ukrainian soldiers wait for
orders they're throwing everything at Us
helicopters artillery bombs how
difficult has it been then to be pushing
forward against them
it's been very difficult he says we pray
to God for more ammunition weapons and
Men a U.S official tells CBS news that
Ukraine's counter-offensive has been
slow and uneven because they're facing
stiffer resistance than expect